hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim
okay uh-oh excuse me
it's alright I had something in my
throat now we are going up the mountain
to try to go for the golden Claude do
team it cheer you are gonna Jack me big
mistake
left us Kris gums ain't this a surprise
that you did haha yeah more yes please
yes please
hello aunt miss aunt doll come here I
don't even know if I'm on the right way
to where I need to go whatever don't
matter I'm out stamina unlikely there we
go I don't even know how that happened
but whatever
hahahaha you laughing at me
well not anymore oh I see I see I I
guess I might come off as pretty vicious
I tried to pretend her like I'm still
playing oh man Daisy to try to loot
things don't know why enters that I
could probably change that if I wanted
to
ooh this would be good opportunity ah no
but they don't have the other piece
armored ah I'll gather them anyway once
I get the armored leggings I'll switch
off so that I'm not in the Imperial
armor I mean not that looks bad but I'm
not sure I want to join the Imperials
just yet
so moving our way up this tower I don't
know if there's any more up here anyone
else up here anyone anyone at all who
would chest yes please you got that all
right not much um that's what I love
about this game there's so many little
things that just have so much goodies
and people to murder while not murder
they're probably they're probably evil
anyway is that a fire whoa what's going
on down there
is there a dragon attacking or something
what is happening okay
that was strange there was just like
gouts of fire if you couldn't see those
it's like fire shooting out onto the
floor something was attacking something
it might have been like a wizard I don't
know see iron grates oh it already got
it I don't need it please sell well not
the shoes really about whatever okay I'm
headed up towards that marker
I think I'm going the right way and
someone's told me how to sprint its left
alt which I don't call it whatever I've
done the wrong way
wait wait uh-oh is my oh it's my thing
pointed in the wrong direction I have no
idea it's a quest AB oh oh oh god oh god
okay all right that's right oh I don't
know why my option menu does that
blinking thing it's like really annoying
it never did that before it just um
started doing it when I started back up
might be a mod that's like not playing
well with the others but who knows it's
only when I opened up the menu so it's
not gonna be that big of a problem I'll
try to figure it out oh hello
come here oh yeah oh yeah didn't stand a
chance
guess my great sword huh oh I need to
level oh there's more
Brett close the distance
oh nothing scarier than charging
Argonian eh ah right in your leg ah ah
ah so mean
ah but they deserve it right cuz they're
bandits bandits I'm narrow sticking out
of me
not in my leg not again on my leg
Steele mmm Steele warhammer hey all but
I like the great sword ah let me give it
a try
might as well it's steel so it's better
right
Tony damaged verse 26 definitely worth
more I don't know it's better but let's
give it a try
oh the beefiness level just went higher
I can now crack coconuts in between my
thighs mmm
to quote my good friend graph ok Spratt
I'll change that to shift later I like
shift I I still need a level at least
the leveling screen doesn't blink like a
mofo ok ah nice colors ok let's see
let's go a bit more health why not
he'd survived ability more than
or two-handed yes please
power tax cost 25 blood salmon battle
Owen I wouldn't be bad I could try that
I don't spread around I'll get the 20%
more games later
I mean I'm only level 3 so I'm just
starting out anyway all right I got here
did good I don't remember this I mean it
has been a while but I mean I'm not my
memory isn't that bad hello were you
talking you having a nice conversation
about a fire or how about not hmm
beefy yeah wonk Oh
oh I I jump agenda spiky Endon get your
[ __ ] you know a lot of games I've
noticed that if it's like an RPG where
the character is moral where you going
the moral passage they'll say like I
don't like you looting bodies and then I
loot every single body I come across
earth I lewd everybody that I kill
personally so it's not really what I
would call moral but whatever at least
my Argonia doesn't seem to have a
problem with it my Argonia doesn't have
a problem with anything especially
bandits hello burial urn give me all
right
no nothing empty empty okay way to go
that's piddly I need more I need more
from my bvr going in I do love love the
grounds in this one one of the biggest
complaints about oblivion one that I
definitely notice is that all the
dungeons looked exactly the same it was
like the same cave layout like this it
really really bumped up the variety
hello come here I got something to say
dia time to get long oh come here
no I'm not now I'm gonna block me with
your torch you think you're doing all
right oh it's one of these puzzles um
okay yeah you gotta line them up with
the mouse yeah yeah yeah you probably
are I knew that I knew that cuz I'm so
smart
we got the snake snake whale snake tank
well fake snake whale that's not a whale
that's a snake cut your car yeah I'm the
man best soul gem is please empty chest
alright
empty what are these Bri learns here
first day ah
Oh startled me huh okay pot pickpocket
pocket pick it I need to take that so it
yeah someone once said in the comments
that they want it they thought argonians
are just for sneaky types
not even close I'm a battle Argonia oh
another one
ha ha ha nope got you both just oh yeah
was it good this stuff from the skiver
tails hmm
women rap for anything scroll a fireball
ease please paralysis potion mmm
yes nope no oh yeah I remember this
guy's an a-hole
take that webs yeah oh hello hey buddy
come here huh honk yes
one warm Wow
oh that hurts kind of hurt buddy
no I can take it ah yeah
oh I'm the victor oh I'm so great i'ma
drop my ego down a couple levels no I
can't Mike is just uncontrollable did
guys a lot of good that lockpick did you
in a cocoon long give me a gaff shut up
buddy I know you're an [ __ ] and
you're just gonna try to run away over
here ah it's coming loose yeah this is
cutting you down oh yeah I didn't even
give you a chance ah yeah
he had the golden claw all right oh oh
yeah conquer it
gold and silver ring
earn and the fist figure what you do
with gems you just sell gems I don't
remember
okay anybody wants some hoop walls so
there Oh someone is there oh it's a
jogger Oh TV oh hello walsim I haven't
quite recovered my health
shut up I don't care well okay maybe I
will
ah don't hang on bro just hold on there
well I actually let me favorite that
favorite all these Laurel nope didn't
hurt
Oh show you how much it didn't hurt
there we go
ancient nord whereas battle not bad odd
damn it
alright I gotta drop some of these
weapons they don't have much value to
them we just drop this top
something's holding you down
well he's an iron armor yeah
that did it yeah row it on the ground
so one more that I killed here ancient
Nords sword not a great sword
I gotta change something it does seem it
seems a little bit dark so close your
eyes if you're [ __ ] cuz I'm about to
open the game menu ah wow it's so oh my
goodness uh-huh oh my god Oh huh
oh okay it's okay we're back oh man that
was horrifying
oh look a trap I think I'll avoid it all
right moving along any more durog or
there's one oh not even gonna give you a
chance get up yeah yeah come on attack
my buddy oh we're coming from behind
block Oh so killed it fighting block bet
wrong Oh hammer to the face I wish there
was like you know I wish it was like
more marilla skin like the hedged explos
and blood old decayed brain go
everywhere at least for the dragger
maybe not for like
people that be bad but come on give me a
Nord the Nord goes no one a Nord
greatsword oh this looks dangerous all
what no also ah oh it's gonna kill me
whoops whoops miss me Shane turned up
yeah there we go
all right make him away any more drug
was that I heard a jogger oh there's one
mmm you got a great sword no you got a
regular Blanc wrong yeah that was a
great sword just try that it's got a lot
of damage weapons let's just drop this
this one too heavy anyway it does it's
got almost as much damage and less
weight I like it I like it
unfavorite that Oh nothing's gonna stop
me now neither you huh nope oh great
sword against crates or he didn't get a
chance
ha block I'm a badass what
ah oh no not today
let me get some food shove it in my face
ah food don't do anything
young mmmmmm with him man I'm gonna be
so fat
oops that I know I'm drunk [ __ ] I'll bet
I need to cook some stuff about book
food before I just shove it shove it in
my face
whoa whoa hey now crowd this is on
expert so it's gonna be going to
actually be oh I didn't know I didn't
need that
Willems are worth much ignored weapons
there they're pretty good damage but
they're just not worth much hmm
I feel so tough
I really should put on a helm it would
be extra armor and I do need some drunk
chop your leg off top your head yeah
chest actually that's all the time I got
for this episode thank you guys so much
for watching
Oleg iron gauntlets but I dropped all
the other I'll wait for a steel armor so
thanks again everybody for watching and
I'll see you in the next episode bye bye